you know i thought it was the right time
i think that uh
with the opportunity that uh joe gave me
to move up and looking at uh you know
the last 10 years i knew that this was
gonna there was going to be a time at
some point in time that this is the
position that was hopefully to move to
and so
gave me the opportunity to move up and i
think it's the right time for me and uh
you know with everything that's gone on
this year and being 60 years old and
uh
really not
you know there's some other things in
life that i'd like to do but i'd still
like to be involved in football so you
know it's a great opportunity for me to
be able to move up still
be you know talk with vic as well as in
the new gm and be a part of the big
decisions and be able to give
my thoughts and my experience where
we're coming and hopefully come out with
the best decision
that's john elway explaining the move
yesterday that on the surface
uh
doesn't seem as positive as he's
selling it to be and
listening to him basically what he's
becoming is the surrogate owner at a
time when there is no owner
and and i think that's the problem the
broncos have had they're in this strange
situation
and it's lasted for years now where pat
boland decided that he was going to put
trustees in place he's got seven
children the trustees have to decide
which of the seven children is suited
and and ready to take over
ownership of the team
it's five six seven years now with no
true owner of the team
and john elway has has thrived not
not necessarily from a football
standport but they won a super bowl but
they've got four straight losing seasons
now
there isn't that same accountability
he's the gm equivalent of john gruden in
las vegas where you're just not getting
fired and in this case
i think the critical i would say he he
fell upward
into this higher role
he he i think he's realized it's not
sustainable with him as general manager
someone else needs to be doing that job
but he's still there and he's still got
final say and he basically is operating
like the owner would operate and my
guess is he'll keep that job until there
is an owner whether it's a member of the
bowling family or which i think is more
likely right now they sell the team well
yeah i mean listen you know john elway
you know again it was a great start to
his gm career you're right the last four
years have not been good there's no
doubt about that there's no denying it
but you know you talk about like the
ownership ownership situation and all
that yeah that's a real factor in this
and has it gave john elway more
power maybe sure it has but you know
they trust him the bowling family they
know john elway loves the city of denver
and loves the damn denver broncos is
gonna do whatever he can to make that
football team better yeah they've fallen
on tough times you know he's missed on a
few draft picks and things like that you
know but he he you know again i think i
put enough in the bank to earn a few
years of like okay it's not been very
good but we're getting to that time here
and this is where i think it's
interesting into what you're saying mike
where it's like
i think another year of mediocrity or
below 500 football and he's the gm
everybody for sure would be calling for
his butt and saying like oh they got to
fire him and do that he stays one step
ahead of the game this way
you know not having his butt be on the
line necessarily kind of more of an
overseer in a managerial type position
he's 60 years old like he said he
doesn't want to be in the grind of
traveling around and looking at every
player and evaluating them all the time
and it made sense i think from that
standpoint and yeah i think what we're
both saying is maybe career
self-preservation a little bit was
involved in this decision too
i think i was involved in it more than
we realized look now there's somebody to
fire once they hire a gm they have
somebody to fire if things aren't going
well when you are the gm you are the guy
who is most likely to be fired when
things don't go well in four straight
losing seasons
most if not all other general managers
aren't going to survive the dysfunction
that we've seen with that football team
with the revolving door at the head
coaching position the revolving door at
the quarterback position we point out
all the time that he can't really
evaluate young quarterbacks he also
doesn't do a very good job of hiring
coaches it's been one after another
after another after another and he was
ready to fire vance joseph after one
year well dude you just hired him a year
ago sure how did you get that wrong if
you're ready to fire him after one year
he gave him a second year and then fired
him and there was a question about vic
fangio well they just hired him two
years ago what are they getting wrong
here so i think they need
a different voice a different mind
and the problem is to get back to what
we discussed last segment
because of elway's presence the job of
gm becomes less attractive
in denver because now you know you've
got to deal with elway the only
difference is you don't have to deal
with an owner if you go into that job
accepting that elway is basically the
owner of the team that that's how he's
operating as a practical matter then
okay maybe but you know the minute they
sell that team you're on the endangered
species list if you take that gm job
well yeah that that's the danger of it
there's no there's no doubt but i also
think within this you know john elway is
not like he's not a jerk he's realistic
he's gonna hire if that when they hire a
gm he's gonna let him run the show and
just be involved in a few decisions here
and there i don't think it's gonna be
about him being involved and nitpicking
in every little thing in the world i
think that's part of the reason why he's
stepping away i think he's also telling
us you know
uh basically that yeah he unders i think
he's kind of saying like yeah we haven't
done the greatest job in the front
office maybe that's why he's moving out
of there and matt russell who's been the
guy that's been his right-hand man for
all these years he's getting out of
there as well they figured out okay yeah
but they had a great run they went to
sue two super bowls you know
afc championship game playoffs all that
but it's fall on tough times and he
thinks this is the right decision for
himself and and probably for the denver
broncos too
here's the danger
okay
the moment you consciously take a step
back from the grind from the work from
the day in and day out
16 hour a day existence
if not more
and and then you're still involved i
still want to be involved right so i
reserve the right to do a drive-by
whenever i feel like it and tell the gm
what he needs to do but you're not in it
every day to truly understand all the
issues and the nuances and the
challenges this isn't a job that can be
done part-time and i feel like that's
kind of what he's doing he's graduating
into this part-time overseer rule
which is fine
as long as you resist the temptation on
a day where you say you know i feel like
going to the facility today and
sticking my nose into what they're doing
and giving them some unsolicited advice
on what they should be doing even though
i'm otherwise not paying attention to
what's going on that's the temptation
that's what he needs to not do sure and
we'll see whether or not he can resist
the urge
you know because he still wants to be
involved he just doesn't want to grind
and i think
when you get to the point in this life
in this job in this industry the way the
nfl is when you're at the point where
you don't want to grind anymore
maybe you just need to unplug all
together well you know i i don't know
necessarily about that i i don't you
know i think he's still gonna grind he
you know i don't know what else he i
don't did you not listen to him well
he's done grinding okay but that's
graduating doing a non-grinding job
that's a different level yeah okay
because that's a different level of
grinding that's you know living in a
hotel taking planes everywhere look into
the size of this guy's calf muscles whoa
look at his butt look at his shoulders
he's sick of that type of grind 16 hours
is nice like you said
it's more like 18 to 20 in a lot of days
so he's had he's the hell with that and
i think he is a smart enough human being
to know
yes like you're talking about
in my experience talking to the guy and
no he he's smart enough to know like all
right i've checked out hey what what are
we trying to accomplish overall as an
organization he's gonna help that out
hey we're gonna make a big trade today
john what do you think of this he'll get
involved in that he's not gonna be into
like okay i think we gotta get a new
backup right guard and all those type of
things like to your point if he starts
getting into that then yeah it's trouble
and it's gonna all fall apart in a hurry
but i think he's smart enough and it's
just the time for for elway to to move
in a different position so good for him
yeah
and
again
now the titans ownership issue is
resolved which kind of quietly lingered
for years and it was a problem for the
league and the league never really
pushed and they got it taken care of the
broncos ownership situation is the hot
topic as it relates to that inside
football
where do we have concerns they're very
concerned about denver and i think
denver as i said earlier it's more
likely that it gets sold than it get
then it gets worked out where one of the
seven bowling children are chosen and
the other six all sign off on it which
is part of what needs to happen there's
too much acrimony there for that to
occur i think that team's getting sold
and that's when john elway is no longer
with the broncos and that's when whoever
takes this gm job has to update the
resume and think about the next move
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports